smart sneakers can sense that you're
walking out of balance and like
compressing or your sneaker telling your
watch that you're walking in a way that
will lead to an injury or your epic
Prada jacket saying that your your body
temperature is hot to her and you might
want to take me off yeah
let me let me show you another France
imagine this Prada logo that we all know
is smart enabled and voice enabled and
you say Prada I love and it has a little
camera I love what she's wearing give me
some recommendations next week on
something similar with that color scheme
correct the pieces are the ingredients
are there it has been cooked yes it
hasn't been cooked so somebody
somebody's listening to this or eating
this please go do that